[Captions by Y Translator]
Normally, it seems
like melting metal with
flashlight would be impossible.
But we're going to take
it to some extremes.
We're going to take an extremely
powerful flashlight,
and a metal with an extremely
low melting point,
and see if we can pull it off.
[Music]
This flashlight has
several settings.
120 lumens,
500 lumens,
1,500 lumens,
5,000 lumens,
13,000 lumens,
and an astonishingly
powerful 32,000 lumens,
which basically lights
up a dark room
as though it were daylight.
And along with all
of that light,
comes a fair amount of heat.
This flashlight gets
pretty good and hot
if you leave it
on that 32,000 lumens setting.
So we're going to take some
of our gallium Lego
figures and whatnot,
and see if we
can melt them down.
The basic premise is simple.
We're going to pour
some molten gallium
into some silicone molds,
and once it freezes,
we're going to see
if we can melt it by using our
giant overpowered flashlight.
We've got some molten gallium,
let's pour ourselves
some Lego men.
[Music]
Our gallium is now solidified,
and I think we can start
taking pieces out of the mold.
Now, I don't think we'll
actually end up melting all
of these with a flashlight,
but some of them, we will,
and that'll be fun.
It will scrap run off
pieces in some places.
Little metallic gemstones here.
[Music]
See how well
our Lego bricks poured.
It's not too bad.
On some of these,
you can actually even
see the word Lego,
and then some of them,
it didn't really
fill the cavity,
and it's just a nice
little round curve bump.
[Music]
[inaudible] are Mongo Lego man.
Oh, it's nice.
Okay R2, how you doing?
[Music]
Got some flashing.
It definitely went up
and over the sides,
but a lot of good
detail in R2D2 here.
Continuing with the
Star Wars theme,
we've got Han Solo in well,
it's not carbonite but close enough.
On both of these,
it didn't quite get
the detail of his face.
So we've got Han Solo
with his face washed out.
One more for the Star Wars,
we've got a stormtrooper helmet.
Oh, that looks amazing!
[Music]
We are going to take
our little Lego man,
set him right here
with our nice black background,
and aim our flashlight at him.
We're going to have
to get this pretty close.
So kind of right there.
We might set the backup
on something here.
About like that.
Let's see how he takes the heat.
As a quick test,
here it is at full brightness.
[Music]
In our first test,
our little Lego man started
to melt a little bit.
In fact, we got a little bit
of gallium dripping off of him,
but we didn't get
the whole thing to puddle,
and our flashlights
started to overheat.
It does put out a lot of heat,
but not all of it
leaves the flashlight.
Some of it just stays inside,
and the casing even
got really hot.
So our flashlight
is cooling down,
and we're going
to try another method
with our little Lego guy.
Our flashlight overheated
with our first test.
So for our second test,
we're going to see
what we can do to cool it down.
This is a giant ice pack.
We're just going to have it sit
right on our giant ice pack,
and then have some more ice
sitting on top of it.
Hopefully, this will keep
our flashlight cool long enough,
that our Lego man
will take the full brunt,
and go down with it.
However,
that's not quite all
we're gonna do to do.
We've also got a piece of foil,
and we're going to build
a little cave over our Lego man
to hold in some of that heat.
We really don't want
him to survive.
[Music]
Let's see what we can do,
with a blowtorch.
[Music]
You know, that looked almost exactly
like the dude in Indiana Jones,
who chose the wrong Goblet.
He just like melts away
from the outside in.
[Music]
So the gallium melted,
but some details from R2D2
are still visible.
I assume that's
where the gallium had oxidized,
or had dust,
or some other chemical substrate
just left on it.
That's so cool.
You can still see some
of that printing even,
though it's now just a puddle.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
Perfect.
That was awesome.
Beautiful.
Melting metal with a flashlight.
It's not very practical,
and it's not very efficient.
But if you use gallium and
a really powerful flashlight,
it is possible to get it to go.
I think gallium is more fun
to melt in some other ways.
It looked really cool.
Pretty much every way.
Every way you melt gallium,
it looks really cool,
and I just discovered
how unbelievably
fragile gallium is when you
freeze it in liquid nitrogen.
So we're definitely going
to do more of that soon.
What do you think?
Anything else you want to see
us try out with our giant,
overpowered flashlight.
Let us know down
in the comments.
Q&A time.
You've got the Qs.
We've hopefully got some A's.
I don't even know
if that makes sense.
We're going to leave it in.
Maybe the editors
will take it out.
I don't know.
I'm not in charge
of these things.
All right, we've got
a question from Dylan Morgan
or @dylanmorgan1122,
and they are asking,
"any new merch coming out soon?"
Dylan, yes, we do have
new merchs coming soon.
I'm actually wearing
a new shirt.
By the time you see this Q&A,
maybe we've already
made the announcement.
It's been on the website
for a while.
I've never been
a huge fan of shirts
that have just like
stuff all over them.
But these are fairly subtle.
Like they've got the TKOR logo,
and just like racing stripes
on the sleeve.
Weather might be getting
a little bit colder soon,
so it's gonna be nice to have
some more long-sleeve stuff.
Ivan Olavarria,
@IvanOlavarria15 asks,
"What's the worst accident
you guys have had?"
I assume that kind of means like
what's the most injured we've been,
or most damage that's been done.
I have been
pretty lucky in that.
I don't think I've really had
anything be severely
damaged on the show.
I don't think I've
really injured myself
severely on the show.
I think the worst injury
of sustained so far was
while I was casting
the Iron Man helmet and candy,
a drip of the molten hot candy
fell out of the mold
and landed on my arm.
I've got a little bit
of a scar here.
That's about nine months old,
and we'll see
if that sticks around forever.
But yeah,
I haven't actually been hurt
very much on the channel so far.
One of the most serious injuries
I've ever received from any sort
of building projects,
you can see I've got a nice
fun scar from now on as well,
my thumb here.
All right, so that,
that will scar right there.
That was me doing
something exceptionally dumb.
I had a little piece of wood,
a 1 by 1 by 1 inch
block of wood,
and I wanted to drill
a hole in it,
and I very foolishly thought,
"Oh, I'll hold the block
while I drill a hole
in it with a drill press,"
and I was holding it,
and then the drill
was going down into it,
and it cut a little bit,
and then it just seized,
and that little 1 inch cube
just started spinning
at the same speed of this drill,
and so it just like spun
and cut into my thumb,
and it actually just like
a chunk of my thumb was missing.
It wasn't just
like a nice little cut.
There is just like,
"Oh, I see
that I'm missing a small portion
of my thumb now,"
and so that was...
I mean, just so dumb.
Don't hold onto things
while you drill it.
You clamp them down,
but that's...
That's probably the most
serious injury I've received.
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't
have to end here.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video,
and you should check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and this bomb in the middle
will subscribe your channel,
so you never miss
out on the video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk you then.